what does this
civilization on mars look like so do you
think
we would more and more you know maybe
start with some genetic modification and
then move to basically cyborgs
increasing integration of electronic
systems computational systems into our
bodies and brains this is a theme of um
uh my other new book out this year which
is called the end of astronauts at the
end of action
co-written with my um uh
old friend and colleague from berkeley
don goldsmith and uh it's really about
the the role of human space flight
versus sort of robotic space flies and
um just to summarize what it says
it argues that the
practical case for sending humans into
space
is getting weaker all the time
as robots get better more capable
robots 50 years ago couldn't do anything
very much but now they could assemble
big structures on space or
in space or on the moon and they could
probably do exploration
well present ones
on mars um can't actually um
do the geology but future ai will be
able to do the geology and already they
can dig on mars and so if you want to do
exploration of mars and of course
even more of um
enceladus or europa where you could
never send humans we depend on robots
and they're far far cheaper because to
send a human to
mars requires
feeding them for 200 days on the journey
there and bringing them back and neither
of those are necessary for robots so the
practical case
for humans is getting very very weak and
if humans go it's only as an adventure
really and so the line in our book
is that um
human space flight
should not be pursued by nasa or public
funding agencies
because it has no practical
purpose
but also because it's especially
expensive if they do it because
they would have to be risk-averse
in launching civilians into space
i could illustrate that by noting that
the shuttle
was launched 135 times
and it had two spectacular failures
which each
killed the seven people in the crew
um and uh it had been mistakenly
presented as safe
for civilians and there was a woman
school teacher killed in one of them it
was a big national trauma and they tried
to make it safer still
but
if you launch into space
just the kind of people prepared to
accept that sort of risk and of course
test pilots and people who go hang
gliding and
go to the south pole etc are prepared to
accept uh a two percent risk at least
for a big challenge then of course you
do it more cheaply
and that's why um uh
i think um human space flies should be
left to the billionaires
um
and their sponsors um because then the
taxpayers aren't paying and they can
launch
simply those people who are prepared
to accept
high risks
space adventure not space tourism yeah
and and we should cheer them on um and
um
as regards where they would go
then um
low earth orbit i suspect can be done
quite cheaply in future but going to
mars
which is very very expensive and
dangerous for humans um the only people
who would go would be
these um adventurers um maybe
on one-way trip like some of the early
polar explorers and magellan and people
like that you know and we would cheer
them on um and
i
expected i they would hope that by the
end of a century
there will be a small community
of such people on mars
um living they uncomfortably far less
comfortably than at the south pole or
the bottom of the ocean or top of
everest but they will be there
and they won't have a certain ticket um
but they'll be there um
incidentally i think it's a dangerous
delusion to think as
elon musk
has said that we can have mass
emigration
from
the earth to mars to escape the earth's
problems um
it's a dangerous illusion because it's
far
easier to deal with climate change on
earth
than to terraform mars to make it
properly habitable to humans and so
there's no planet beef or risk-averse
people but for these crazy adventurers
then you can imagine that
they would be trying to live on mars as
um as great pioneers and by the end of
the century
then there will be huge advances
compared to the present
in two things first in in understanding
genetics
so is to genetically redesign one's
offspring and secondly to use cyborg
techniques to
implant some something in our brain or
indeed think about downloading etc and
those techniques will
one hopes be heavily regulated on earth
on potentials
and ethical grounds and of course we are
pretty well adapted to the earth so we
don't have the incentive to do these
things in the way they were there uh so
um
our argument is that um it'll be those
crazy pioneers on mars
using all these
scientific advances which will be
controlled here
away from the regulators
they will
transition into a new post-human species
and so um if they do that and if they
transition into something which is
electronic
eventually because there may be some
limits to the capacity of flesh and
blood brains anyways
then um those electronic entities um may
not want to stay on the planet like mars
they may want to go go away and so
they'll be the precursors of the future
um evolution of life and intelligence
coming from the earth and of course
there's one
point which perhaps astronomers are more
aware of than most people
most people are aware that we are the
outcome of four billion years of
evolution
most of them nonetheless probably think
that we humans
are somehow the culmination
the top of the tree
but yes
no astronomers can believe that because
astronomers know
that the earth
is four and a half billion years old
the sun has been shining for that length
of time but the sun has got six billion
years more to go before it flares up and
engulfs the inner planet so so this
doesn't happen through its life um and
the expanding universe goes on far
longer still maybe forever and i like to
quote woody allen who said eternity is
very long especially towards the end
so
so we shouldn't think of ourselves as
maybe even the halfway stage
in the emergence of
cosmic complexity and so these entities
who are postcurses they will go beyond
the solar system and of course even if
there's nothing else out there already
then they could uh populate the the rest
of the galaxy
and maybe eventually meet the others who
are out there expanding as well yeah
expanding and populating yes with
expanded
uh capacity for life and intelligence
all those kinds of things well
they might um but um uh
again
all better off because i can't conceive
what they'd be like
they won't they won't be uh um
green green men and women with eyes on
stalks you know maybe something quite
different um
we just don't know um but there is an
interesting question actually which
comes up when i've sometimes spoken to
audiences about this topic but the
question of consciousness and
self-awareness because you know going
back to philosophical questions i mean
whether an electronic robot
would uh be a zombie or would it be
conscious and self-aware
and um um i think there's no way of
answering this empirically
and
some people think that consciousness and
self-awareness is an emerging property
in any sufficiently complicated networks
that they would be others say well maybe
it's something special to the flesh and
blood that we're made of we don't know
um and
in a sense this may not matter um to the
way peop things behave because we
they could be zombies and still
behave as though they were intelligent
but
i remember
after one of my talks someone came up
and said
wouldn't it be sad
if
these future entities which were the
main challenges in the universe um had
no self-awareness so there was nothing
which could appreciate the wonder and
mystery of the universe
and the beauty of the universe in the
way that we do
um and so it does perhaps affect one's
perspective of whether
you welcome or deplore
this possible future scenario depending
on whether you think the the future
post-human entities are
conscious and have an aesthetic sense or
whether they're just zombies
and uh of course you have to be humble
to realize that
self-awareness may not be the
highest form of being
that
humans have a very strong ego
and a very strong sense of identity
like personal identity connected to this
particular brain
it's not so obvious to me that that is
somehow
the
the highest achievement
of a life form
that may be this kind of thing something
collective would be
it's possible that uh
well
i think from an alien perspective when
you look at earth
it's not so obvious to me that
individual humans are the atoms of
intelligence
it could be the entire organism together
the collective intelligence and so we
humans think of ourselves as individuals
we dress up we wear ties and suits and
we give each other prizes but in reality
the intelligence the things we create
that are beautiful emerges from our
interaction with each other and that may
be where the intelligence is ideas
jumping from one person to another over
generations yes but we have experiences
where we
can appreciate yes
beauty and wonder and all that and uh
a zombie may not have those experiences
yeah or it may have a very different
they do have a very black and white
harsh description of zhan like a
philosophical zombie zombie that could
be just a very different way to
experience
and you know
in terms of the explorers that colonize
mars
i
um i mean there's several things i want
to mention one
it's just at a high level to me that's
one of the most inspiring things humans
can do
is reach out into the unknown that's in
the space of ideas in the space of
science but also the explorers yes
and that inspires people here on earth
more
i mean it did
in their you know when going to the moon
or going out to space in the 20th
century that inspired a generation of
scientists
i think that also
could be used to inspire a generation of
new scientists in the 21st century by
reaching out towards mars so
in that sense i think what elon musk and
others are doing is actually quite
inspiring it's not well i agree
it's not a recreational thing it's
actually has a deep humanitarian purpose
of really
inspiring the world and then on the
other one to push back and your thought
you know i don't think elon says
we want to escape earth's problems
it's more that we should allocate some
small percentage of resources to have a
backup plan
and because yes you yourself have spoken
about and written about
all the ways we clever humans could
destroy ourselves
and i'm not sure
it does seem when you look at the long
arc
of human history
it seems
almost obvious that we need to become a
multi-planetary species over a period if
we are to survive many centuries
it seems that
as we get clever and clearer with the
ways we can destroy ourselves
earth is going to become less and less
safe
so in that sense
this is one of the things you know
people talk about climate change
and then we need to respond to climate
change and that's a long-term investment
we need to make but it's not really long
term it's a span of decades
i think what elon is doing is a really
long-term investment
we should be working on multi-planetary
colonization now if we were to have it
ready five centuries from now
and so taking those early steps
and then also there's something happens
when you're caught when you
go into the unknown and do this really
difficult thing you discover something
very new you discover something about
robotics or materials engineering or
nutrition or neuroscience or human
relations or political systems that
actually work well with humans you
discover all those things and so it's a
it's worthy effort to go out there
and uh
try to become cyborgs
yeah no i agree with that i think the
only different point i'd make is that um
this is going to be very expensive
if it's done in a risk-averse way and
that's why i think we should be grateful
to uh the billionaires if they're going
to sort of foster um
these opportunities uh for uh
thrill-seeking uh risk-takers who we can
all admire yeah by the way i should push
back on the billionaires because there's
sometimes a negative connotation to the
world billionaire it's not a billionaire
it's a company versus government because
governments are billionaires and
trillionaires yeah it's not it's not the
wealth it's the the capitalist
uh imperative
so uh
which i think
deserves a lot more praise than people
are giving it i'm i'm troubled by the
sort of criticism like it's billionaires
playing with toys
for their own pleasure
i think
what some of these companies like spacex
and blue origin are doing
is some of the most inspiring
engineering and even scientific work
ever done in human history
no no i agree i think the people who've
made the greatest wealth are people
who've really been mega benefactors i
mean i think you know
some of them some of you yeah yeah so
some of them but but those who've
founded um
google and all that and uh and even
amazon
they're they're they're beneficiaries
then they're quite different category in
my view from those who just shuffle
around money um or
or
or um or crypto coins and things like
that who are
now you're really talking trash yes
but
but i think
if they use their money in these ways
that's fine but but i think um it's true
that the far more money is owned by us
collectively as taxpayers but i think
the fact is
that in a democracy um
to be big resistance
to exposing human beings to very high
risks if in a sense we share
responsibility for it yeah i don't know
and that's that's the reason i think
you'll be done much more cheaply by
by by these private funders that's an
interesting hypothesis but i have to
push back i don't know if it's obvious
why nasa spends so much money
and takes such a long time
to develop the things he was doing so
before elon musk came along
because i would love i would love to
live in a world where government
actually uses taxpayer money to get some
of the best engineers and scientists in
the world and actually work across
governments
russia china united states european
union together to do some of these big
projects it's strange that elon is able
to do this
much cheaper much faster
it could have to be do with risk
aversion you're right but i think it's
it's the
it's that it's that he had all the um uh
the whole assembly within this one
building as it were rather than
depending on the supply chain um but i
think it's also uh that he um had a
silicon valley culture and a younger
people whereas um the the big aerospace
companies boeing and lockheed martin um
they had people who were left over from
the apollo program in some cases and
and so they weren't quite quite so
lively and indeed um quite apart from
the controversial issues of the future
of human space flights um in terms of
the uh next generation of big rockets
then uh the one that uh musk is going to
launch for the first time this year
um the huge one um it's going to be far
far cheaper
than the one that nasa's been working on
at the same time um and that's because
it will have a reusable first stage
and it's going to be great it can launch
over a hundred tons
into earth orbit and instead that's
going to be
make it feasible to do things that i
used to think were crazy like having
solar energy from space that's no longer
so crazy if you can do that
and also
for science because um its nose cone
could
contain within it something uh as big as
the entire unfurled james webb telescope
mirror
and therefore you can
have a big telescope much more cheaply
if you can launch it all in one piece
and so it's going to be hugely
beneficial to science and to any
practical use of space to have these
cheaper rockets that are far more
completely reusable than anyways nasa
had so i think mosques are a tremendous
service to the
space exploration and the whole space
technology through these rockets
certainly plus it's some
big sexy rocket it's just great
engineering of course yeah yeah it's
like looking at a beautiful big bridge
that humans are capable us descendants
of apes are capable to do something so
majestic yes and also the way they land
coming down on this bar that's amazing
it's both controls engineering it's
um
increasing sort of intelligence in these
rockets but also
great propulsion engineering materials
in your ship and it just inspires it
just inspires so many people no i'm
entirely with you on that yeah
so
would it be exciting to you to see a
human being step foot on mars in your
lifetime
yes i think it's unlikely in my lifetime
since i'm i'm so ancient but uh but i
think this this century is going to
happen
and i think that that will indeed be
exciting and uh
i hope there will be a small community
by the end of a century and but as as i
say i think they they may
go with one-way tickets or accepting the
risk of
of no return and so they've got to be
people like that and
i still think it's going to be
hard to persuade the public
to send people when you say straight out
that they may never come back
um but uh of course the apollo
astronauts they took a high risk and in
fact in in my um previous book i i quote
the
speech that's been written for nixon
to be read out if neil armstrong got
stuck on the moon and yeah
and he it was written by one of his um
his advisers um and very eloquent speech
you know
about
how they would have come to a noble end
etc um but of course there was a genuine
risk at that time
but
but
that
may have been accepted but
um clearly the
crashes of the shuttle
were not acceptable to the american
public
even when they were told that this was
only a two percent risk given how often
they launched it and so that's what
leads me to think that um
it's got to be left to the kind of
um people who are prepared to take these
risks and i think um uh think of
american adventures as a guy called
steve fossett who was a
aviation did all kinds of crazy things
you know uh and then a guy who fell um
supersonically
um
with the parachute from very held
altitude all these people we all cheer
them on they extend the bounds of
humanity
but
i don't think the public would be so
happy to fund them
and i mean i disagree with that i think
if we change the narrative we should
change the story you think so i think i
think there's a lot of people
because the the the public is happy to
fund
uh folks in other domains that take bold
giant risks first of all military for
example military and memphis obviously
yes yes um i think this is in the name
of science especially if it's sold
correctly i sure as hell would go up
there with the risk with the i would
take a 40 chance risk of death
for something that's
i would i might want to be even older
than i am now
i guess what i'm trying to communicate
is there's all there's a lot of people
on earth that's the nice feature and i'm
sure there's going to be a significant
percentage or some percentage of people
that are they take on the risk for the
adventure
so and i i particularly love that that
risk of adventure when taking on
inspires people and just the ripple
effect it has across a generation
especially among the young minds is
perhaps immeasurable
but
you're thinking
that
sending humans
should be something we do less and less
sending humans to space that it should
be primarily an effort
the work of space exploration should be
done primarily by robots well i think it
it can be done much more cheaply
obviously on on mars and uh
no one's thinking of sending humans to
enceladus or europa the outer planets um
and uh
and the point is we'll have much better
uh robots because um uh let's take an
example um uh you see these pictures of
um uh
the moons of saturn and the picture of
pluto
and the comet taken by uh
probes and cassini spent 13 years
going around saturn and his moons after
seven year voyage and those are all
based on 1990s technology
and if you think of how smartphones have
advanced in 20 years since then just
think how much better one could do
instrumenting some very small
sophisticated probe that could send
dozens of them to explore the outer
planets and that's that's the way to do
that because no one thinks you could
send humans that far um and uh but i
would apply the same argument to to uh
mars and if you want to assemble big
structures like um
for instance radio astronomers would
like to have a big radio telescope on
the far side of the moon so it's away
from the
earth's
background artificial radio waves um and
that could be
done by assembling
using robots without people so
on the moon and on mars
i think
everything that's useful can be done by
machines much more cheaply than by
humans
you